nous voici à stanstead à deux pas de la
frontière avec l'état américain du
vermont les 106 y est affiché à tout
près de 2 et 14 le litre d'après 25 $
d'essence dans mon petit réservoir de
moto qui normalement coûte à peu près
tous à 13 alors
ce prix est déjà avantageux
comparativement à ce qu'on peut payer
dans les villes comme magog sherbrooke
où montréal mais traverser la frontière
pour remplir le réservoir peut valoir la
peine mais j'habite aussi en selle mais
nous avons un chalet aussi essai
auvergnat de 15 minutes d'ici plus on
traverse à chaque semaine ou deux fois
plus cher que les semaines qui s'est
vraiment juste mais moins cher
à deux vilaines le prix pour un gallon
d'essence est de 5 $ et 10 cents
américains ça équivaut à environ 1
dollar et 72 cents canadiens le litre
[Musique]
avec ce flot de canadiens qui cherchent
à économiser les commerçants du coin
font de bonnes affaires mon mari est
professeur plutôt que moi vers 5 heures
l'après midi puis avait une file d'un
bertrand québécoise en ligne juste pour
l'atteinte des comices de godillots
peaches elles vont des come back again
des soldats rwandais 14 j'ai aussi
le propriétaire de cette citation
services estime que les québécois sont
responsables d'une augmentation
d'environ 25% de son chiffre d'affaires
alors que les canadiens ont le sentiment
d'avoir économisé
les américains sont amers de voir le
prix à la pompe constamment grimper
la flambée du prix de l'essence
s'observe à l'échelle mondiale et
exacerbée par le conflit entre la russie
et l'ukraine selon des experts il faudra
attendre encore plusieurs semaines avant
d'espérer un frein à la hausse des prix
ici marie hélène rousseau radio-canada à
2001 au vermont